[Music]
four years ago I was basically
unemployed I wonder with no home
but now I'm a husband and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way
and I did a boss
my job was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
half a billion people
of every known species in the sea
call this place home
but that doesn't mean they'll like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds there
I'm gonna murder his family
and burn his kingdom to Ash
he must be stopped for a global meltdown
is imminent
I think I know someone might be able to
help us
you look rough
good job brother high five do not call
me brother
I cannot believe you let this happen
yeah well I hate this job true king
built Bridges right
King builds Bridges
we need to find Manta he's different now
he's stronger than before
it's the black Trident
during King atlan's time there were
Seven Kingdoms and I tried it it was a
curse upon them all
kind of start magic is spreading
he means to end the bloodline
[Music]
I don't know if I said but we can't
leave our children in a world without
hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
if you lead the Seven Kingdoms will
follow
[Music]
thank you